wdrb.com says lmpd that's louisville
metro police
plan for armed militias to protest
downtown saturday
and they give us this really this really
really nice photo of a member of the
black militia group known as the nfac
you got a bunch of dudes they got guns
and i'll tell you what first and
foremost they are in their legal right
to do everything they're doing
absolutely so good for them that's first
of all trigger discipline
trigger yeah i mean seriously compared
to a lot of people these guys are doing
it right
well after the first time that they they
marched what was it like three weeks ago
maybe a month yeah
i don't know so there was a bunch of
people talking about
the you know the different people
holding guns and then
then there was close-ups on the guns and
then there was
close-ups and calling out on how many of
the guns weren't loaded
many of the guns weren't uh from from
the nfac yeah
interesting weren't uh properly you know
equipped i guess i mean maybe they don't
know that much about guns you know
myself but i was reading into it and
they were like there was
clearly people who knew what they were
talking about guns so talking about it
the the important context is that you've
got this group it's the the not effing
around coalition
they marched through georgia they called
out right-wing groups
and militias and apparently one of these
dudes has posted
like i don't know how you describe it
but anti-semitic conspiracy theories
you know stuff in the vein of like black
identity extremism and black hebrew
israelites
so people are kind of concerned about
their ideology especially gonna be
marching around but hey you know first
and foremost they're allowed to be doing
this america
second amendment applies to uh to them
same as anybody else if they want to you
know do their thing
so long as it's you know within the law
yep i'm not going to complain
however the three percenters are going
to be coming out and after these dudes
already called out
other militias yeah i have genuine
concern for
like some kind of escalation i really
don't want that but you know i don't
want anyone shooting each other but
but i got to be honest man i've i've
noticed that when i've gone to a lot of
protests okay
be it the left or the right the armed
guys are the most disciplined
and typically stop things from
escalating the issue is
the older disciplined guys with training
who are like we don't want an escalation
here and kind of calm things down
they're great but what happens when some
younger person shows up all rambunctious
with a brand new weapon or like when the
dude in chaz just hands some random dude
a gun
or a brick gets tossed from behind the
crowd or you know
one one person not associated with
either group comes in and just pops one
shot into the air while pretending to be
one or the other
exactly and then i think i gotta be
honest man in my experience i think even
someone firing in the air
you'll see discipline from the guys who
are properly trained they're not just
going to start aiming and shooting
well what scares me though on that front
is these
not effing around crew they were
straight up calling
these people to come fight them yep so
they weren't
i mean that's what they were saying
they're like come fight us you know you
you're all talk and it's like
they're not all talk they're that they
they're not trying to fight you that's
not what their plan is and that seems
like that's what their plan is
perhaps perhaps i can't speak for the
nfac guys okay
i've i've actually been on the ground at
various uh protests and actions where
the three percenters have been
yeah and i've seen them be very the most
disciplined there in fact
at one event it was in boston when
people were trying to fight the three
percenters actually
pushed the so they're on the side with
the right the right wing people okay
when the left-wing people started
walking up to the crowd the three
percenters actually
like held back the right-wing side
telling and yelling at him like back up
back up now
because they they're they're disciplined
they're assertive and they're like
you're gonna cause problems
that guy's trying to bait you you back
up nice because they they're gonna keep
like
if the three the the three percent of
dudes in boston
they knew that if they went up to the
antifa guy and tried pushing him back
like get away from us the fight would
break out
the smart thing to do the discipline
thing to do was to con was to tell your
side
to back up because they're trying to
bait you yeah so i really do believe
that if if if this if it really did come
to this if i had to make a bet i don't i
wouldn't say i'd guarantee it
i'd be willing to bet it would take a
lot to get like a three percenter group
or one of these right-wing wishes
to engage like even in the event someone
fired a few rounds i bet they would
retreat i bet they would get behind
cover
and they'd be like we're not engaging
this is not what we want
i can't speak for the nfac well i can't
i can't either
all i'm saying i'm never i don't know
well and neither do i but i am going
directly off of their videos
of them right through the camera saying
this is our message
so i'm i'm going off their words that's
that's where i got my information here
let's read a little bit they say groups
associated with a three percenter
movement and a black militia known in
the
known as the not effing around coalition
are expected to
face off in jefferson square park on
saturday along with other people who
have for several weeks been protesting
the fatal shooting of brianna taylor by
police well maybe maybe they'll all be
there together because
everybody wants justice for briana
taylor yeah
period i don't know any i haven't found
one person
who doesn't care about that yeah i i
would say that uh with uh with 100
accuracy
when i go to people and be like hey did
you hear about this young woman who was
just like
shot in a no-knock warrant and they're
like wow that's crazy those cops should
face justice like okay yeah
yep i'll tell you what though in uh
seattle
there's going to be more riots on
saturday and that's why trump is
deploying this tactical team
saturday's going to be bumping that's
that's tomorrow man it's going to be
it's going to be bumping there's going
to be a lot of live streams
things are going to get crazy across
this country i hope this doesn't spark
any any any
any craziness let's read a little bit
more same major aubrey gregory told
reporters thursday that the groups are
expected to be
armed but everyone police have spoken
with has expressed the desire for
peaceful protests
we have been in contact with both groups
coming to louisville and we expect
nothing but a peaceful protest this
weekend that's what i was saying man
i i even with the tough talk from the
dude yeah i've found that the people at
protests who are armed tend to be to be
much more disciplined yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if both groups
were like no no no no we don't
nobody wants to get shot right i mean
right some places are a different story
mind you chicago for instance people
pull out guns and point them each
other's faces and then somebody gets
shot
yep to help ensure that police will
limit vehicle access around the park
including prohibiting parking on the
streets surrounding jefferson square
park
and police will use bike rack barriers
to create a buffer zone
and separate the protesters gregory said
police will create a no-go
zone on 5th street to try and keep those
people with alternative viewpoints
separated
the department will try not to intervene
as long as protesters do not break the
law police have said
lmpd remains committed to peaceful
expression of views under the first
amendment
that's uh jesse halliday police
spokesman said as we have done for
several weeks
there will be no need for police
intervention as long as there is no
threat to personal or public safety
we will not allow the barricading of
streets by non-law enforcement impeding
traffic or attempting to threaten or
force people not involved in the protest
from their intended destinations gregory
said the department has been in contact
with other law enforcement including
kentucky state police
but have not requested assistance for
this weekend and gregory told reporters
he spoke with
the founder of nfac grand master jay who
said he is coming to louisville to voice
his concern
over the death of taylor but expected a
non-violent protest
i take him at his word as i have no
reason not to
nice i think they should march together
i think so too good point
they shouldn't they should they should
both show up and both say
we want accountability for people who
break the law and commit crimes and
taking us in life
absolutely what if if they approach this
as they're framing it like different
factions
needing to be divided well that's
clearly what they're doing exactly
that's the potential for conflict
because you'll get some anti-foot dude
on one side
starting to fight all right if they
march together like we saw with black
lives matter and the boogaloo boys yeah
zero chance for conflict that's true
because what and who who's antifa gonna
like
provoke you know if they're they're
going together as
as proper american citizens exercising
their rights
you know protesting against uh an
injustice
you know what what's antifa going to do
who are they going to push look at what
happened in virginia
when all the gun rights advocates came
out and black panthers showed up
everybody had everyone had a good time
and guess what they won that's true they
they pushed back that law i suppose in
virginia
i can't remember the full it's been a
while since i covered this but they had
their big peaceful protest
they actually won and different
political factions were there
all getting along mostly just like guns
right activists i think there was you
know
i'm sure many of them have different
viewpoints but that was the only real
clear ideology
i got one word for you what's that
america yeah
absolutely yep isn't it funny how
peaceful protest works
yeah martin luther king was
was a very a strong advocate for
peaceful protesting
what have the violent violent riots
wrought
opposition to black lives matter
escalation of ruination of small
businesses minority-owned businesses
yep destruction of wealth for the lower
class literal death
and then we get the defunding of police
they claim victory what does that get
the the deaths but look at new york look
at chicago and the activists in new york
are coming out saying
bring them back please bring our crops
back yeah so the riots
have have generated nothing but chaos
conflict
suffering death 28 dead
28 i know it's more than that but well
directly involved in rioting
sure then you go on to the crime rates
that are surging because of this stuff
worse what of the peaceful protests
generated
at first peaceful protests resulted in a
major
show of support for black lives matter
yes and now it's all souring
well because at first everyone was like
hey you know what you're right we
we want you to know we absolutely think
black lives matter no doubt
like we there that wasn't even a
question on anyone's mind
right away it was like awesome black
lives matter for sure no doubt yeah but
now
now we see it's being commandeered by
all these
not just one but just like there's
antifa that's taking it and using it as
a shield you know corporations
corporations are using it right you know
they're jumping on the bandwagon it's
boston was the boss in red sox they're
like a 250
foot banner that's so dumb man
you know you know we i did a video on
this earlier but when
a e canceled live pd oh yeah that's
right
this is this is this is so crazy i don't
know if you guys saw the story
it's a 300 million dollar franchise
and a e was like it's a show about cops
we're gonna cancel it and now their
ratings are down 55
good riddance not only did they lose the
300 million dollar franchise but the
revenue across the board is going to go
down
you can't have can't have a video
showing police in a positive light can
you
nope you know the adage uh you know
we should make a button get whoa go bro
i got a few i got yeah that's a good one
actually
relevant it's happening a lot yeah we
need something having to do with aoc
giving bread to people
let them eat cake let them have bread i
can't believe she actually said let them
eat cake you know what i mean wait she
actually said
let them figuratively oh okay like when
she was referencing the shooting
violence and crime and she was like they
just want bread
that's like literally i know it's just
the poor people are revolting again what
should we do why don't they just eat
bread
because they don't have any dude but
that she
but hers is a different version of the
same thing
where it's like hers is an inversion of
it where people aren't trying to get
bread and she goes
we need to give them bread it's like
they're shooting each other for
unknown reasons for asking for someone
asking them to
stop lighting fireworks yes 30 in the
morning yeah that's an issue of law and
order
absolutely it is they're trying to claim
that trump is faking
all of this which is insanity this is
yeah
seeing it with my own eyes i i'm reading
the police reports it's
it's crazy right now in america like i
want law and order the only people are
getting killed
go ahead the only conspiracy theory is i
suppose
the the the black black individuals are
secretly working for the government
and so some believe it or not some
people actually believe this because
they think the two people who are
snatched up were actually informants
yeah we talked about that right yeah
yeah so that's why the cops were like
we're going to get you that's why they
weren't arrested and there was no trace
of it
they weren't running for quest they're
technically brought in for questioning
but they're cooperating criminal
informants
or confidential informants but uh i
don't i don't think there's any grand
conspiracy i think the reality is i
i've known a lot of these far-left
people they want people to believe
they tweet about this they're agitators
trying to make us look bad
the protesters are peaceful it's like
dude those moms weren't wearing masks
they were kicking the door in two
like it's just a mob it's like this is
what mobs do
it was a really funny story i was
reading once like i guess it's like an
old legend
that somewhere in europe back in the way
olden days of like the 1400s
okay people were all on a bridge just
dancing wildly
like for no reason and whenever someone
walked on the bridge they would be they
would succumb to the hysteria and start
dancing as well
okay and it was just like it was just it
probably it's a story supposedly about
some weird curse i don't know but
most people just think it was mob
mentality that people joined in and
started doing random things looking
weird and silly for no
known reason i mean i there's i'm seeing
some videos where there is definitely
mob mentality and they're just chiming
in
it's creepy and that's why i'm saying
real creepy the fact that they're
showing up to people's homes now
yeah is one of the most alarming things
because it will only be a matter of time
before they go in your home
and that and that's why that i don't
know if it was the police commissioner
or who was who made that press
conference but he was saying it's like
we've had like over 17 of our police
officers be doxxed by these antifa folk
yeah we don't want th they're like
they're going to people's houses
yup we know that they are so we're
trying to protect our officers
who are trying to protect the citizens
who aren't
attacking the courthouse it's crazy but
this is what we get in the pacific
northwest
if you know i mean i'm pretty sure
everybody realized this especially with
like andy knows coverage
yeah that if it was going to start
anywhere this unrest and this wave of
whatever
is it going to be in portland or seattle
we all knew it you know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you